2 to 6 percent of people describe themselves as
They have an attraction factor for homosexuality
While there are many social and political theories about why,
What does science say? Is homosexuality genetic,
If so, do we all have a homosexuality gene?
In the 1990s, two studies using the Human Genome Project
I found that paraplegic men had more equal relatives than men of heterosexuals
And gay brothers have similar ties
On the X chromosome, demonstrating a high level of genetic inheritance.
A recent study of more than four hundred and nine
Equivalent siblings also found links in a particular area
Of X chromosome labeled Xq28
And in another area of ​​chromosome 8.
Moreover the 2014 analysis of fifty years of research
The two men found that they were more likely to have twin brothers
Compared with the possibility of heterosexual men and lesbians
Lesbian sisters, suggesting their qualities are
Genetically linked.
But, if homosexuality, in fact, hereditary,
Does not this create a paradox?
While some people like sex, they still have children,
Overall they have children 80%
Of the variants
Does not it mean that the genes will not pass and disappear in the end?
Well, a recent study by the University of California uses epigenetics
To suggest that everyone has a homeopathic gene,
But whether the Methyl group facility is specified or not
DNA zones are turned on and converted.
Genetics is a study of how your environment is
It can chemically modify your genes.
Such as how to diet for the queen of ants and phyromons
Chemically the fetal ants can either be chemically altered
Soldier or ant worker
Based on what is required of the colony.
The twin study was used, one of them being gay and the other different
And found that a certain methyl pattern is closely related
To sexual orientation.
The model was able to predict sexual orientation in men accurately 70%
But these data used a small subset of people,
There is some controversy about research.
In the end, certain gay genes were not found, but scientific evidence
Suggest that sexual orientation is human
It is strongly linked to genetics and is tightly regulated at the molecular level.
So it was found that the birth of a son
Increases the likelihood of homosexuality in the next son
33% for the population.
If the older brother of a different mother, there is no effect.
This has prompted some researchers to believe that male pregnancy
Leading to a biological mechanism that affects the successive birth of the mother.
A meta-analysis was found
Statistically, gay men
They have older brothers than heterosexuals.
Another study found women who were exposed to high levels of testosterone in their womb
They have higher rates to be different.
Why does this happen?
The hypothesis of homosexuality suggests that homosexual family members who do not reproduce
Are still increasing the spread of their family genes
In future generations
By helping to provide resources for the offspring to which they are associated
But the family is correct.
Studies also show that there are lower levels of hostility
Higher levels of emotional intelligence,
Mercy and cooperation in the two men,
Which may also increase altruism and survival in human groups.
Another hypothesis suggests that genes are homosexuality
Are the ultimate codec to attract
This means female relatives of the two men who share the same gene
They will also have strong attraction factors for men,
Providing an evolutionary advantage.
Studies have shown that these females have more children on average.
The same is true for lesbians and their opposite male relatives
World famous EO Wilson once said
"Homeopathy gives advantages to the group.
The community that condemns homosexuality condemns itself. "
Historically, science has not been good for the Quer population.
In the past, it was generally accepted that
The bodies and minds of the two were under pressure to be
From a lower status, with a popular belief that gay behavior
It was the result of flawed development.
Even some LGBTQ + community are afraid of this scientific research
It can be used to hurt people
Even from the available research, it is clear that most
Just focus on gay men and neglect other groups.
But more research on genetic and genetic factors about homosexuality
Will reduce anti-homelong laws around the world
By proving that homosexuality is not a choice
But, genetically, can we get rid of homosexuality?
Watch the second video where we discuss whether it's possible and its implications
Of the ongoing study in this field.
And subscribe to the scientific videos more every week every Thursday. Translation: GEX